Is An Almighty mate and it's people the
length and breads of the UK who are
paying the price of this you know I
think Liz truss's early resignation as
prime minister was probably inevitable
the moment she walked into Downing
Street but let's trust isn't the problem
here she's the symptom of a much more
fundamental problem you know a broken
Tory party certainly but also a broken
UK political system what needs to happen
now well on a UK level there must be a
general election it is a democratic
necessity the idea that the Tories can
unite behind a prime minister now any
prime minister let alone one that is in
the public interest I think is for the
birds but fundamentally at the UK now
needs to have a democratic Choice over
its next prime minister there's even
ludicrous suggestions this afternoon
that Boris Johnson is going to try to
make a comeback so that's what what
needs to happen immediately of course
for Scotland that doesn't really solve
the fundamental to problem because
Scotland's votes don't determine the
outcome of UK general elections so as
long as we're part of this Westminster
system we're always going to be
vulnerable to getting Prime Ministers we
don't vote for implementing policies
that we don't support and do real damage
to the country for Scotland the only way
we get Prime Ministers and governments
that the greater number of us vote for
is to be independent and I think the
Democratic case for Independence is
growing literally with every hour that
passes